I love doing my job I get to take people
on all these fantastic adventures it's a
rough place
neither you're safe and you come home or
you screw up and you don't come home we
have to be a little bit more minimal
with the stopping or else we're gonna
get in trouble start digging and our
team is trying basically do an MRI of
Mount Erebus it's a really unique
volcano and the fact that it erupts a
sort of bizarre magma type of the fauna
light which is pretty rare but can erupt
really violently there's no doubt in my
mind that we're on terrain that has
crevasses underneath it we can't see I
have to poke around and really have a
good inspection of the site kind of
feeling in the snow for the consistency
in the snow depth there's always some
risk of falling into carafes
I've had very close friends died and
crevasse falls in situations just like
what we're dealing with here so for me
it's something that's very real so my
job is to decide if it's safe enough for
the scientists to install all the fancy
stuff out here every minute counts we've
got a really efficient yet the job done
our goal for this project is to make
measurements at 132 different locations
around Mount Erebus creating a map of
the insides of the volcano hey guys I
think it looks good to get out it's a
nice accumulation zone so there's lots
of snow here and it's a nice compression
area as well so I think as long as we
keep it nice and tight we should be fine
it's gonna bump our asleep in the last
36 hours for me but that's a good hole
this little box is the brains of the
operation out here and is basically a
really really fancy data collector we've
got to really try and get all the work
we need to done because what we're doing
is we're gonna be applicable to the
volcanoes and similar geologic settings
all over the world we just hope that
what we do is meaning and beneficial for
for those that come next there we go
working now we're good